hallo deutsche schule deutsch lernen mit
spaß das ist ein hamburger
der hamburger ist ungesund
er bestellt einen hamburger
er ist den hamburger das ist ein
hamburger
der hamburger ist ungesund
er bestellt
einen hamburger er ist den hamburgern
das ist ein kleid das kleid ist rosa
nicole sucht ein kleid
sie findet ein kleid
sie probiert das kleid an
das ist ein kleid das kleid ist rosa
nicole sucht ein kleid
sie probiert das kleid an
das ist
eine lampe die lampe ist aus
er schaltet die lampe an
das ist eine ampel die ampel leuchtet
rot
martin wechselt eine lampe er schaltet
die lampe an
das sind bücher
die bücher sind aus papier
monika interessiert sich für bücher
sie liest die bücher das sind bücher die
bücher sind aus papier
moni
interessiert sich für bücher sie liest
die bücher
ein mann
der mann
trinkt ein bier
eine frau die frau ist pasta
ein kind das kind
spielt
leute die leute
tanzen
essen markus ist einen hamburger
trinken tina trinkt einen kaffee
kaufen
daniel kauft ein geschenk
das geschenk ist für die freundin
ohne die brille kann er nichts sehen
die einbrecherin kommt durch das fenster
lisa geht in den supermarkt wohin
anton hängt das bild an die wand wohin
stefan springt in den eimer
wohin
domina tief akkusativ
hat dir das video gefallen abonniere
unseren kanal hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal abonniere die
halo deutsch schule auch auf instagram
oder facebook abonniere die halo
deutsche schule auch auf instagram oder
facebook nicht vergessen dieses video zu
liken zu kommentieren und zu teilen
nicht vergessen dieses video zu liken zu
kommentieren um zu teilen